but he's keeping us guessing levon
he's finally back at the board and we're
ready to go here we go the english
opening so um okay again just like the
first uh first game today we see this
position will he repeat his strategy
which nearly brought him success simon
yeah um i i
again you say he's a man of principle uh
he often sticks to what he uh what he
has played earlier on and and he's doing
exactly that now he's going well there
is a big decision here and it looks like
he's going to go for the same setup the
retti that quiet set up where he got
actually to be fair extremely good
chances
to win so i mean why change why change
if it's worked already why not stick and
where ye maybe they've had a chance to
look at some improvements exactly the
same as we saw in the first game yeah
what do you think will we ye be the
first one to differ uh the first one to
change up the move order maybe because
he was like
i think he has to right
i mean for sure
levon has spoken to someone or he's at
least consulted the computer and come up
with a small improvement but at the
minute they're playing exactly the same
so in that last game in this position
white's rook came across so it's still
exactly the same in first 10 moves from
aronian in that game black's queen just
sidestepped one square and maybe that
was the start of things going wrong
where he moved his queen three times in
the first um 20-so moves in that game
and it did backfire so okay the first uh
the first new move instead of using the
black queen on the c8 square the black
rook has come to that c8 square and uh
this is much more logical this is much
more natural at least the black queen's
still on the central file so white's
rook is that is peering down at it but
the center is still temporarily closed
do you think we will see one of these
type of positions where white looks like
they're not really doing too much they
kind of move the the d pawn one square
forward and then they just huddle and
then
they strike they expand as much as they
can on the right kind of chest yes just
step one square wait wait wait step
another square yes
that strategy is not really level style
i guess we saw him in the in the first
game of the day when he had white he
went for the center you caught him mr
center last season uh ivanka so i do
expect him to occupy the center with
pawns but no he does go for that
slower option
interesting stuff and way he's clearly
prepared for this game he's clearly
looked at it in the break this last rook
move you don't make it you don't play
immediately without having studied the
position
the whole idea of black's last rook
moved down to the seventh round because
the black queen can actually slide into
the corner at some point uh where she
does sit on a surprisingly good diagonal
okay levon meanwhile comes out with a
white knight and the way he looked off
to the left with his eyes briefly means
he's trying to remember something
you mentioned uh maybe he's talked to
someone before this game do we know
anything about who lavonne is working
with uh levon um that's a good question
i don't really know these days i
mentioned lenia dominguez sometimes they
do live close to each other in the u.s
fabiano quite possibly he's worked with
those guys maybe even ahead of the
olympiad some of the american players
they got together maybe a training camp
there i know he used to work with
several armenian players often the
younger generation who would kind of
give him energetic ideas and fresh ideas
he loves as he's as we saw in his tweets
he loves kind of picking the brains of
the new generation uh who work a lot on
chess but yeah i don't know these days
levon i think maybe a bunch of people
yeah
and it was a very interesting
developments in the game because i was
thinking okay well the game is going to
go
into the long haul you know white is
going to creep forward black is also
going to do some funny maneuverings but
the way he's like no he pushes forward
with this pawn which is also very
thematic but funnily enough
no one has ever played this pawn move
he's studied it he's prepared this
novelty look at this clock time
when he's been surprised in the past
where he stops to think now he's up on
16 minutes gained time
he's clearly studied this novelty before
he's playing instantly every move the
white knight came forward attacking the
black rook
we see a bunch of exchanges now
and it's still level material but
he's trying to intimidate levon he's
trying to bully him with all these quick
moves he's actually giving up a pawn
where ye
black central pawn the d4 pawn can just
be captured what's the idea there
for ye can it be captured i mean uh you
capture with the knight do you i guess
because if you take with uh the bishop
then i can just nudge your night away
um so you have to take the knight and uh
just destroy this yeah
this would not end well for white two
pieces attacked so you have to capture
with the knight instead
and then i guess i guess black has some
energetic moves attacking the cool hello
oh oh oh oh
i nearly there's this we've got to show
this idea this one i nearly played that
one without thinking but i it might be
possible but let's just can we just show
queen takes pawn
very quickly king takes and then knight
f5
double check and then nicki
can go back it looks like you're about
to deliver checkmate yeah it looks like
the king is trapped but the black knight
does guard this square yeah
unfortunately it doesn't quite work and
uh
um
has he actually taken it again he has so
knight g4 that night jump is critical
can and if wei yi has prepared this
then surely he must look at taking the
pawn because you're playing so quickly
you've got to look at your opponent's
most critical move unless the computer
says it's losing and he has played it
wow what's happening here i mean this is
this is
this is going to be good for someone
really good for someone the valuation
bar thinks it's very good for black and
in the current position as we showed
level and running can't sacrifice his
queen you can even jump forward with
this check for example a double check
hitting the bishop uh hitting the king
with the bishop knight but when the king
moves unfortunately you can take the
black queen but it's not enough black
emerges with an extra knight
for three pawns but the knight will
become the dominant factor and in the
current position
where else to put the queen for love on
iranian if he retreats to this square
hitting the knight then rook takes
knight is just a winning move simply
in this position the knight and bishop
are far superior to white's rook in
return so black has two pieces for the
rook and will be winning where else do
you put the queen i am i'm struggling
here if you move
uh to this square there will be
consequences at the very least black
could support this knight and push
forward with a double attack next move
i'm also wondering for example if the
queen goes to this square or
especially if it goes to the square next
to
its own knight to continue protecting
then what about this one knight takes
pawn
and a pin along this diagonal black will
win the night back with interest level
pawns but white king will be very very
open and
yeah and i wondered whether there was
any funky moves as well so you know the
position is so strange i mean current
position
no i think this one is really good for
black uh the current position but if you
look at the the game position
then i just wondered whether there was
anything
strange
like
knight takes pawn well knight takes pawn
counter-attacking so the queen was under
attack but now we're hitting the black
queen i guess the idea is that after the
night captures and
who what do we play now this knight is
attacked this knight is attacked
why is two pawns up temporarily
that's interesting yeah what to do but
maybe the night the white nights while
sitting pretty he's probably trapped
right oh it's trapped right now so maybe
we can defend the black knight yeah
temporarily we defend the night we
threaten maybe a night check jumping out
the way when there will be tension
between the bishops so after a trade
here white's knight has to save itself
and at the very end this rook drops i i
think iranian's just being tricked yeah
i think simply he's kept up with his
same strategy and moving very quickly
but it's been a really s
silly decision uh in this because it's
clear that wei yi has prepared this and
the move that kind of shocked me was
this knight takes pawn in the middle and
the speed he played it because it's one
of those moves which is probably either
winning or losing it's nothing in the
middle ground because you're either
winning a pawn or you're failing falling
into some trap that where ye has now
launched so i'm just amazed that lev
actually played that so quickly you know
i mean that work you know he's done this
throughout but in this critical moments
and you must
be aware of what your opponent's trying
to do and i
i mean with that bit clever bishop f6
move that you showed there david and and
just i'm just feeling that way he's
prepared this so it must be good as well
it's just simple psychology otherwise he
wouldn't be moving so quickly yeah
and is it a case that lives in serious
trouble now i i think he is absolutely
in trouble and uh i love this selfie
what's this well do i like it
well i was also this kind of decision by
lavon really reminds me of that phrase
that we use when you get married really
quickly marion haste repent at leisure
and uh yeah so when it
well whilst uh levon is just thinking
about what to do his position is bad
well we see some selfies i'd also like
to share with you some selfies and uh
one is from carlos madurga who sends us
greetings from catalona
and uh there you will see there's a cat
watching our show hi we are big fans of
pets here
and kirk also sends us our best wishes
and he says we make a great team so
thank you kirk and uh we hope you
enjoying watching the show and uh cosmon
tells us that today was tournament day
but
they were lucky enough to make a quick
win and come back home to watch lavon
against way fantasy
good game of chess
watching some fantastic players yeah
well battle there
just battle it out against each other
and if you two want to share with us
your selfies or send us your thoughts
your questions then please tweet us
using the hashtag chestchamps and don't
forget we have a crypto cup challenge
where we're asking you to guess
that we'll not guess the name 30
30 or as many grandmasters as you can
within 30 seconds yeah that's a
challenge that is a very cool challenge
i think i i might try it yeah and you
can i mean this challenge will be going
on for the entire fdx summer chess with
also the major coming up in august fdx
crypto cup so you can uh practice and do
it again and again now levon aronian is
the one thinking in this game and i
guess uh it was wei you were talking
about actually david that has been
talking to someone has a great
preparation in this game clearly and
there we go uh the preparation continues
we're at move 21 where he's barely
pausing for thought he's just given up
the black knight and we showed this
variation earlier black's bishop pins
the white knight and level neroli and he
is walking into the lion's den wow look
at the white king
what is it doing in the middle of the
ball it doesn't even help right wow i
mean yes
it's bad news when the king is a
defender of
a piece and there's still
four rooks and two queens on the board i
mean the first move that kind of comes
to mind is just uh well i just attacked
the knight
with a pawn yeah yeah there's several
tempting moves in this position but uh
i mean
this can't end well for white simply
with this king in the center um so
sufficiently protected right now is the
knight defended three times attacked
only three times as well but yeah as you
guys said push this pawn the whole idea
is that if the queen takes the pawn we
slide across with either rook to be
honest and this is a skewer you win the
white queen
you pin and you win here but uh
what's his idea if the black pawn steps
forward is he just going to run with his
king this way
that's the only justification i can make
for the white king coming out into the
center you don't want to like kind of
run away with your tail between your
legs back to the king side
there's actually less
pawn protection on that flank maybe his
idea is to drop back with the king and
after a set of exchanges actually maybe
here he wants to hide with his king
is the king safe on this flank
i mean it's so ugly
this position black can gain a bunch of
time against the white queen by pushing
forward black can move his queen out the
way for example somewhere start lining
up his two rooks against this white
backward pawn on d3
yeah just looks like one way traffic
right now level number of pawns but
um in the current position if we go back
does wei yi have something stronger than
this pawn push that is the big question
because right now white's king bishop
and queen are all tied down to the
defense of this knight maybe you don't
even need to attack it yet maybe you can
move the white queen out the black queen
out the way somewhere
maybe you can
i don't know push a pawn move this rook
across prepare this idea
yeah so many options looks good just
wait and do nothing i mean what does
white play if you just push your pawn
forward and laugh
say okay i don't even need to win my
piece back that's a mean girl move there
david uh it's
it's brutal yeah this is coming next
yeah
yeah it's strange because uh
i mean obviously lev's fallen into
something pretty horrible here but the
advantage is not a material advantage i
think it's worth pointing out but when
when that knight is captured in the
middle which it will be equal on points
but it's a positional advantage and
the positional advantage is if you look
at black's rook and queen in the middle
of the board they're just fantastically
pointing down that row look at the white
king the white king is naked you know
it's lost its clothes feeling a bit cold
black's king super safe and there's all
these little things and at this level
you you kind of think these things are
are really enough to win the game but
how about if he moves his rook behind
his queen would they be better the white
room and the white rock yes yeah i guess
at some point the problem for white is
that um this pawn can easily be defended
in the center for black for example if
black just makes a move uh say we push
upon
here this pawn can be easily defended so
it's actually a strong point if you
compare it to white's backwood porn this
pawn is completely blockaded
not that easy to defend long term
black would love to initiate what we
call alakine's gun and just kind of
zigzag his rook
to this square and then all three pieces
the ammunition all facing down on this
pawn it's going to be weak forever
and uh meanwhile black has more space
black has the safer king as simon
mentioned also black does have ways to
attack this king he could throw this
pawn forward later open things up
wow what if we do get that alekhine's
gun simon is that when we start singing
welcome to the danger zone you know
that was the devoted number one
cheesiest song well that doesn't
surprise me to be honest
i haven't even seen the new top gun film
has anyone seen it no i actually haven't
but i'm uh it's on my list definitely on
my list yeah good things from our
different skill yeah yeah that's a great
movie yeah gotta see it gotta say it so
uh but yeah this is this is also a very
good move played and it just it just
looks like uh
black's got an ideal position it's just
king safety as well isn't it i mean look
at the white king the white king is just
looking ridiculous totally there ain't
no maverick king there no that's that's
more of a goose
goose king there in the middle i can't
even remember the characters in the
first one but who's the ice man out of
these
the iceman is he's he's cool he's cool
val kilmer he's um it must be the black
bishop the black bishop must be the ice
man which of these two players where he
all the players that's a good point
who's the maverick who's the ice man
who's oh well i would say aronians are
more experienced he's like the ice man
and the youngster has to be the maverick
right the sort of young the young upshot
you know come along trying to trying to
stir the pot a little bit
um with his fantastic
um but you know maverick was a bit
outside the box wasn't he so i don't
know
so
not really even a maverick really to be
honest more i think about it
when you guys say iceman because
obviously i've never seen top gone
before oh i just haven't um but when you
say that i think of the
arnold schwarzenegger classic
running man running man's very good as
well yeah yeah classic phone that's a
great film and uh here i was wondering
in this type of position i mean is there
any chance for white i mean like in
general things so it looks so unpleasant
so maybe we can jump in and try and find
a move for whites it's uh ivanka calls
it so unpleasant and again it's just
this pin how do we break the pin maybe
you have to meet the king david don't
you i mean just at some point charlie
he's scummy away right yeah and we drop
this knight anyway at least now you can
hide on this square and it's similar to
that variation we showed the main
difference though is that this black
pawn
is actually on a pretty safe square
maybe it's actually good for wei yi that
he hasn't committed this pawn if you
push it forward it can be a bit weak it
can be a target here it's easier for
black to start creeping in maybe using
his queen along this line
it just looks really really scary for
white he has run away indeed with his
king and actually instead of moving his
king across where there would have been
this direct tactic of a nasty check
we saw a capture instead and uh here
after a capture white's queen simply
drops back
but it's all about creating the alakan
gun now i would love to see where you
just lift his rook up one square and if
he does so
then how is white going to react i mean
the king can move the black rook's
sliding across we call this alakine's
gun because it's the three heavy pieces
stacked up together it's like uh when
you pull the trigger eventually one of
these pieces will win this pawn you
can't right now but you will maybe break
through and uh win this pawn but yeah
this allocates gun is just so powerful
all the heavy pieces
i can imagine a situation where as well
the black queen is freed up because the
rooks protect each other she can start
jumping into the position somehow from
this angle black's pawns can start
pushing forward and uh trying to open
things up
was it alakina and who invented this
alekhine's gun or was he just famous for
using it
he was famous for using it right i mean
he had two two games uh where he got
this configuration of rook and queen um
so they yeah they named it after you
know the games that he had in this
position
i'm sure it had been done before you
know like many things in chess but you
know of course nothing else yeah he's
suddenly like oh having two rooks and a
queen in the same line that must be a
good idea in chess
i mean here level iranian wishes better
gun control because this looks really
uh yeah really deadly and uh okay he
doesn't go for this i'm really surprised
he i mean this was so tempting for me
instead of putting all the pieces on the
uh i mean you could have done it this
way as well with the queen kind of
sandwiched in between the rooks normally
you want the queen behind because she's
the most valuable she's kind of
propelling the gun forward but uh
instead of this he just pushes in the
center
and white's king sidesteps
what is the idea now
still a very nice position i mean
white is purely passive here uh why
can't we do anything and i think he's
going to do sort of what is this it's
not quite aligned alekhine's gun is this
like i don't know trevor's gun or
something
nice because the order has to be queen
um behind yeah yeah behind two works
yeah
yeah but it still looks very strong as
simon says i mean you're threatening to
come in this way maybe you're also
possibly lining up this diagonal against
the white king it's all gone wrong for
iranian level material but
it's the quality of the pieces all in
black's favor the pawn structure all in
black's favor
very least you could start marching this
pawn down the board and start pushing
again but uh
kaya you called this earlier actually
rook lining up behind the white queen
you predicted it um this had to be done
in order to improve this rook later this
looks sad sitting in the corner it wants
to swing across and defend
but the the bar just uh goes uh further
up for wei yi this is game three he has
the black pieces but do you guys think
he will take the the lead in this uh
first match
it looks very likely wow i mean if wadi
doesn't win this then he'll start
questioning himself he'll think if i
can't win this i can't win anything
because it's strategic
domination right now yeah but
i don't know if somehow wei yi doesn't
look like the kind of player who would
collapse after a bad game it kind of
looks like he could just
take a sip of tea
and get on with it
some players do have this great power of
recovery others you you just know that
that's it
they're going to collapse
and famous tilt yeah
well
he still has almost 11 minutes on the
clock you guys were praising his
preparation in this game so do we know
anything about who he's working with is
it the chinese team working together
yeah i think it's other chinese players
i know he has worked with ding loren in
the past i'm not sure whether he worked
with him recently ahead of the
candidates for example um of course they
had this famous match when ding was
trying to qualify for the candidates he
had to play a whole bunch of games and
i think 10 of those 28 games were they
were against wei yi wow uh so
a sparring partner at the very least but
which is a pretty good sparring partner
the world number two
but
yeah either way
he definitely works with well and the
top players and maybe he helped ding in
the candidates of course as one of his
seconds and we we know right that uh
players who have been seconds especially
for for big tournaments like candidates
or world championship matches they often
do thrive after helping those players
yeah exactly um i mean magnus helped a
second for anand and then later on he
took the title from anand
we saw
magnus when he defended the title in
2000
was it 18 and uh daniel dubois had just
been working with him suddenly daniel
dubois went and won the world rapping
championship yeah so working with strong
players i mean it's never a bad thing
you learn from it
and that actually happened to one of my
friends
she employed a grand master
and together they worked on an opening
repertoire and novelties to help her in
the women's world championship she
didn't get any of them
but he did
he got in every single one of the
novelties and the ideas that they'd
hatched up and he won literally every
single open open that he played wow and
so she said next time you pay me yeah
sheep yeah okay she paid him yeah and
here
that's a great job
all right well now he's thinking though
wei
thinking hard in this game he must sense
that this is the game he could win this
is the first match in the final
tomorrow will be the other match
but everything can still happen the
pitfall for wei yi is to think too long
first of all but also there's too many
tempting moves
you can pretty much do anything here as
black um the only i mean i can only see
one move which blunders and or a couple
of moves which blunder and uh would ruin
the position for example if we jump in
you have to keep defending your rook if
you jump in with the queen to this
square for example then whoops you are
actually pinned on the central file so
black white's queen can capture one rook
and suddenly this is disaster on the
back rank
so you have to be slightly careful there
with that in mind in the current
position i would love to maybe just
create some space and breathing space
for the black king
if you want to sit
there's no current threat so you could
just push this pawn you could just maybe
push this pawn forward white will never
ever capture you because suddenly the
white king will be open along the c file
so
yeah just too much choice maybe that is
the problem and
do you think where you should just take
your time out just push a pawn create
some lift for the king should he support
this pawn to free up the black rook
maybe
so much choice i think you should just
play some natural moves like you say i
mean it's quite a simple position really
um there's not really any danger unless
you blunder
but you can nearly play any move on the
board and and be better
so you if i was black i'd just be
looking at ways to improve my position
so like i i like the ones supporting the
pawn in the middle
and just move your pieces to better
squares and do that and just you know
all the ideas you said but just playing
quickly there's no reason really to mess
around here because there's not anything
to calculate at the moment um so it's
peculiar that he's uh now gone lower
than aronian on time i mean uh there's
strange forcing variations and he spent
five minutes yeah so it's not
calculation here
uh the name of the game is
i mean he's looking up drinking tea what
did what is he thinking about he should
just be getting on with it pushing
forwards or like you said simon just
calmly maneuvering but
the only thing he can be thinking of is
his pawn push i guess which you
mentioned okay uh trying trying to
do the damage immediately maybe this
side yeah i mean this is the only one
where you might calculate because it
gets a bit complicated any other move is
not really complicated so why bother
spending time on it i'd say unless it's
this one yeah that one as well yeah i
just don't think that works but
um
it's maybe back up on the d file maybe
you know yeah i can break in here but
white will just defend against that
i mean it's still very dangerous i still
rather be black there definitely is it
going for it wow almost six minutes yeah
so he doesn't make sense push this pawn
he's going for glory immediately he
didn't need to this is again difference
of generations i think we would have
just solidified things slowly built up
the position but he goes for it
immediately but if it works it works i
guess that's so maybe now it's
understandable why you fought so long
because
you need to calculate this one carefully
even if it's not the best move it looks
good enough to maintain a big advantage
and it does ask level neroni and who's
also short in time uh it asks him some
big questions and
first question is
can you leave this pawn the answer is
not really it's attacked by black's pawn
black's rook you have to really capture
and second question once that happens is
how do you stop the infiltration
of black's rook to the second rank that
would be deadly if black hits one more
move and gives a check
yeah if you stop it with your rook the
problem is you can't challenge rooks
right now bringing the rook across black
actually
covers the square three times so black
would win a piece
but uh yeah if you stop it this way
suddenly the white queen gets hit
if the white queen moves for example
then the black queen is coming in this
it looks awfully strong
that's that's a disaster for white
um
i mean the king is not going to survive
this
absolutely not
going to survive in general
maybe in this position can he just move
his rook try to pretend he castled
on the side of the wood it's it's a
start right shaq i mean it looks like
checkmate somehow maybe the queen just
comes in but maybe you can be clever
about it and uh yep that looks great
yeah i mean it's still not the end of
the world have to wait what's the
rockford it looks scary
yeah this is surely wedding day isn't it
yeah surely whoa
yeah it's not i mean i'm clutching at
straws trying to defend this one but
maybe you know is it yeah no but here i
feel like you do have to be concrete as
well with the attack
so
i do think pawn how about this
one
moving the rook i'm hoping that after
pawn takes pawn i can play queen takes
pawn yeah so that was a check and now
i'm trying to get her through to your
back rank
hmm
this looks uh i mean i'm just trying to
think now getting into the mind of levon
aronian in this current position either
you play pawn takes pawn and you
do or die along the d file you have to
protect against this or you need
something genius can you try to get the
queens off i mean black's queen is
terrifying what if you move the queen
maybe yeah
and then you have to answer this check
then it runs
yeah
at least this one yeah all that i didn't
even see it was checkers that's quite
quite lucky but maybe it's all right
yeah yeah i'm still actually yeah
yeah it looks like you're losing the
queen but nope you're getting through
happy little accident
and maybe white's all right there
somehow flukes here
maybe maybe you need this type of luck
in the position okay so we're thinking
that currently level iranians should not
play pawn takes pawn otherwise he might
be in big big trouble maybe he needs a
clever move offering a queen trade or
just swinging his rook across and hoping
for the best your rook d1 looks very
interesting as well it looks kind of
but
actually i just checked the computer
there are just two ways to save this and
uh first top choice is simon's move over
that fancy queen move second choice uh
is actually the slide the rook to d1
square those are the only two everything
else gives like a completely winning
advantage they are both findable for
lavon we found them but
with a bit of luck just by process of
elimination we look to the most obvious
move pawn takes pawn it looks like white
was losing there so then we look for
alternatives if you can't play pawn
spawn this pawn is attacked that's how i
stumbled across this move although
calculation is needed and
simon just thought okay we can't play
pawn takes pawn we need the queen's off
so he found maybe the best move in the
position but i i i found the move but
then i realized i lost my queen so it
was like but it works happy little
accident make your own luck
so will he find this queen move or this
rook move if not levon can almost resign
wow three minutes on the clock he has to
find queen f4 or bring his rock across
okay
we just need to look at the board right
now will he find one of those two moves
he has been thinking for a long time so
i guess process of elimination
that's at that point
i the one thing i noticed with okay
wow i was literally about to say the one
thing with top players is if you give
them a small kind of uh selection if
they know that everything is losing they
figure it out
nearly always they find the best move or
they find the path to survival they use
that process of elimination
by calculating and
yeah he finds great incredible yeah i
mean
yeah
i mean is it i guess black must still be
a lot better here but at least at least
now black has the decision
about what to play right wings can't
come off the black if the queen's come
off white is probably all right yeah so
yeah i mean
maybe
i guess so yeah that's the back rank
which is a real problem for black in in
a lot of these variations right so
exactly black's king would love to have
a breathing space uh breeding square
black's queen needs to move i think
as we saw pawn takes pawn it's a check
hitting the white king but the white
king just steps up one square and
because of the tension on the e file
with the rooks
black is not actually doing as well as
it looks like yeah probably the best
move is for the the queen just to go to
the edge of the board
just a3 a3
and then just just to stop the white
rook joining in the action then you've
got to worry about rook takes pawn oh
god i i don't know i mean
you have to at least calculate maybe
black's still doing okay though but i
mean for example now if this captures
which it would love to then white does
have a queen check
this isn't checkmate because black's
queen can come back and defend but this
is what we're talking about if the
queens disappear um suddenly white is
completely fine if anyone's better it's
white
with queens off the board because
white's king is suddenly active it's a
target while queens remain but if the
queens disappear it's a great piece in
the end game
so
yeah just to show the other variation as
well um after pawn takes pawn check
hitting the king the king steps forward
the problem for black is no time to take
the queen uh if you take the queen then
this again check the queen drops back
more trades and at the very end actually
white wins with an extra rook
so
yeah i mean in this position there's so
much action happening black for example
can play brook takes rook but firstly
white can just recapture secondly the
question is maybe just queen takes queen
again we see an end game white is
temporarily a pawn down but he threatens
checkmate and when that is stopped white
can simply come and pick up this pawn
again it was one of those cases where
where ye played this move
very sharp move so he's entering the
complications but maybe it's a very good
move and maybe it's the computer's top
choices pawn push but i think nearly any
one of my generation at least who's not
you know trained with a computer would
have just played something very quickly
kept the pressure on and i think that's
the more practical way to play because
you give your opponent more chance to go
wrong when you play like this you're
forcing them to find a move that aronian
played
you're giving them more opportunity to
play the right moves i think i think
it's more practical to just to keep the
position unless you've got a real
knockout maybe he thought that move was
knockout i guess i guess that's the
thing but it's still still where
easy in hindsight say i mean i suspect i
bet black must be better and okay has
come over this yeah logical move as well
this is a nice move
yeah after my last foray with the queen
i was like oh this does not like it yeah
it feels wrong for black i gotta say it
crossed my mind as well but if suddenly
this rook is unprotected this rook is
unprotected
is there a way to somehow take advantage
of this
for example at the very least
i was going to say the root coming
across i'm not 100 sure about that
is this a threat that's the problem is
black threatening to play pawn takes
pawn with a check he wasn't threatening
it on the last move maybe he's
threatening it now the one thing white
shouldn't do of course is play pawn
takes pawn himself
because after a rook trade here black
will win with a discover check for
example if white tries to check mate
there's a really nice block black and
retreat
no checkmate for white because actually
white is the one under check first and
the queen drops off next move instead
levon
found a better try he
moved his rook across
and evaluation bar going back in black's
favor after a check now at least the
white king steps forward
what is the idea here for black
you've got to be really careful rook
takes rook suddenly whoops again
checkmate coming
so many traps suddenly in the position
it's very complicated and uh in light of
all those uh back rank mate ideas maybe
you can just take a timeout
give the king some air
after all white isn't really going to be
capturing the pawn because it's not
ready yeah this is a very good choice i
think here ivanka um i'm slightly
worried of why white steps the king
forward that will hit the rook and lose
a pawn but i think you can move your you
know rook this rook coming over so yeah
maybe it's just enough for uh for black
to keep the advantage
yeah so i mean practical terms just move
the pawn don't get checkmated on the
back rank yeah and keep the game going i
look at the attention and the time i
love it when they get to this stage of
the time because i have to admit like
they go through the stages they have
their long things so then suddenly they
get to like two and a half minutes and
it's like okay wakey wakey time yeah
we're gonna get the action now is coming
and um
there's loads of just little tricks here
aren't there loads of little tricks for
both sides and i i'm i'm thinking even
though the bar's over at wae's side that
it's not as good as it should be
okay so he's now done this move and that
allows
it allows ronin at least to try and
survive in an ending right
i mean take that rook off the board
and i don't i i just don't like the way
he's done this i have to say about a
really good defensive player like way or
the way he's done it
i quite like the way and i like way way
and sneaky trap there from levon yeah
yeah exactly i should not be tempted to
capture the rook because of the back
rank checkmating motifs that david's
highlighted earlier can i just mention
one thing yeah because this is so tense
right these players they're fighting for
the winner takes on 25 thousand dollars
top players in the world
and they live on irony and they're
sitting in his home with his vacuum
cleaner in the background
i think it is a backup oh wow
it's actually good to know that he does
his own cleaning yes
a man like a roni and you'd assume he
has a team of cleaners
to to clean for him
anyways i just uh noticed that uh drama
on the board with a vacuum cleaner in
the background has that vacuum cleaner
always been there i don't know we
haven't seen it no all right because
we've
he's been sort of uh he's been leaning
that way lavon so i don't think the
camera has uh
seen it maybe he's trying to send kind
of some subliminal messages
he's trying to say okay this game's not
going well for me let's get the vacuum
cleaner out hoover off all the rooks the
queens the pawns and make a draw
but uh yeah this this game white white
is still upon down suit it's irony and
defending but
i mean there are some clever moves yeah
yeah yeah queen coming over here
is looks very very natural we're
expecting white's queen to actually
slide across two squares to the d-file
trying to tempt black to take it black's
rook is stuck on the background can
remember stopping all those nasty
checkmates i reckon
that way ye might have
missed that
just in his calculation i think he
probably realizes it now
but it's not necessarily the most
natural move to
to see i mean maybe you calculate those
aggressive moves the queen jumping
forward attacking the rook you say okay
i've got that one covered
does anyone want to have a little bet
i just feel the way this is going
and i didn't even mean to say that
but the way
with emphasis just say that again this
is going that aronia will win this game
you think
not well not really i just fancy a
better
well david would you like to have a beer
on that one i'll say where you will
still win then let's have a beer on it
okay okay someone is saying lavon
winning and you might go saying you're
drunk yeah okay so so i'm to go for a
liv all right so yeah let's do it yeah
yeah okay okay all right someone's
getting paid yeah this is getting
interesting now okay
and in no way that's a significant bat
exactly yeah
okay
he needs to do something black still has
this extra pawn the d pawn
how is he going to fend off
or regain that pawn he needs to get the
queens off the board that's levon's
number one priority if you can get the
queens off the board he is safe
even upon down because white's king is
so good and black's pawn won't survive
he does move his queen across
his idea was to defend it with his okay
bang bang bang the music wait quick
there's a check black's queen could
slide the whole way across with the
check oh hello
yes forcing the white king back
this gets really messy
and you have to give this checkers black
black's queen
is under threat the black rook remember
cannot move it cannot come and capture
the white queen because of the white
rook going to e8 the top rank and
checkmating black
and then you're going to be
sneaky okay and let's play that king has
to step back and are you going to be
sneaky and just like move the b pawn
forward
well you can get a draw here if you said
about the bear and he's like i want to
get your rank of that beer
i'll just move the queen to and fro to
secure the jaw a draw yeah draw black's
queen can come in as you mentioned simon
to the d2 square with a check white's
king has to go back to the edge of the
board and then you can just move the
black rook maybe
is that
an idea yeah therefore you keep your
pawn alive you keep the black d3 pawn
alive this guy check white king had to
go up the board if it went back then
black the white rook would have fallen
with a check
so now you suggest moving the rook
somewhere safe yeah tuck the rook next
to the black king yeah pretend you've
just castled yep
everything protected then rookie free
then you
wow
oh maybe the white king might well have
to start stepping up the border yeah
he's going to have to
and look at the times so exciting
they're both under a minute now and
aronia's king has walked
from one side of the board to the other
the walk of death but he's holding on
with these like crazy little tactics
okay i'm gonna say where he's definitely
gonna position once we see that from him
of course i mean yesterday against his
report he repeated the position so many
times and then played for the win so
second time we've seen this position
we're expecting black's rook to move
just to guard any background checkmates
but he really should play for a win now
i i mean but he's also i'm thinking from
a psychological point of view
he's going to be a bit annoyed because
he realizes he had an easy win somewhere
and now and now he's like i've got to
calculate this why am i not winning and
that's why i'm kind of betting on a
ronin i think he you know his this this
does affect you even if you are the ice
man
the ice the ice the way the ice way the
way of the ice the ice okay well he has
too much time he's now ticking to ten
seconds
and uh he does move his rook
and not to a particularly safe square
you can see like he's pounced he knows
this is his moment this is his time to
defend but again he doesn't have too
much time either 40 seconds i mean for
me i think i would probably just move my
queen well what about moving the r i
like the idea of moving the rook i mean
to stop that check maybe right in the
center of the board and i can try to get
it back try to win your pawn get to an
ending so i'm thinking move it up how
many squares one two like four squares
okay e5 e5 yeah yeah that's or maybe e3
rookie three as well is the same idea
black porn makes a lot of sense yeah
he has to move move the rook
he goes for it i don't know i felt that
this was a bit too uh it was very
logical as well though yeah but it
allows the rook just to live on the c8
square and it was a blunder okay where
he repeats the position once where is
the win for black make a hole for the
no you can't there is no maybe you can
push the pawn forward
can you yes you can push the pawn
forward the b pawn forward okay and
after white's rook takes then you give a
check and then i'm hoping that there's
going to be more checks and the root
gets involved and there's happy times
just guessing at this point though
10 seconds left for wei he made a move
look at the bar it's alive he's missed
it i mean i don't want to cheer for one
side but come on aronian
come on
get in there son
evaluation back on black side though
treating the queen look how open the
white king is this is the problem
and uh okay a big threat on the board
black's queen wants to take the white a
pawn levant steps back nice and calm
yeah the quick the key thing is that if
black's pawn steps forward the d-pawn
white rook will slide behind it
to stop and occasionally is he going to
take the draw
he can't take the draw but i mean he's
got to find something if you don't find
something
you probably take the draw he hasn't
he's only got 10 seconds
where is the win
this is winning
two seconds okay
wow three seconds wow but maybe this is
not enough okay but no now now you know
wow now if we get the queens off we're
better
now someone gets the queens off you're
winning king is just gonna run forward
so you just need to get the queens off
is the king going to survive while the
queens are on that's a big question
first just take that black pawn off the
board i don't care how i'll just take it
yeah
it's too dangerous
probably the rook feels more natural
doesn't it but
yeah somehow it feels like the white
king shouldn't survive be interesting to
see what a win was maybe it was your
move your anchor that uh rather you know
they didn't have enough time to
calculate but something like b5
felt like the right option it was it was
my b5 really right okay but it's nice
one move it's about the sequence he
clearly spotted that but what is the
winning idea behind that we'll go back
later we'll try and investigate
where where you can play the pawn he
doesn't take the pawn well i'd have
grabbed that one i mean it's so
dangerous and
he's he's moved in and maybe he's
thinking of some perpetual whoa what is
this oh where ye has sacrificed his rook
um guys
it's not a draw yet
he can take he can is he not gonna just
repeat no because he could take the rook
and isn't black just i don't know why
it's not just winning here then it's a
draw if you take the white rook white
has a petrol check does he yes yeah so
if you ever take the white rook we will
show this then the game will be a draw
so yes yes your anchor looking very
clever here at the moment
a few drinks yeah because
he's given up his rook so he needs
something now but there's nothing more
than a draw look at where ye suddenly he
sunk down in his chair
he's blown it is there any way levon can
win this or is it simply a draw
white can win if black doesn't take the
draw black has to take the draw keep
repeating don't let white's king out
because simply white's a
rook up and i think we might well see
the rook being captured
okay no the position continues to repeat
white's king goes to the corner back
where it came from
wow what a game again once again miracle
save by leveled ironian
yeah i mean this one is gone now for wei
yi nothing else to do but take the draw
i think there's a good lesson to be
learned there even though ye's pawn move
was probably very good it just wasn't a
very good practical choice and you've
got to you know sometimes take the
practical human choice and look at the
volaronian shaking his head i guess he
got a little lucky in this game three
but it is a draw that means they are
still tied one more game to play